california plans to lift nearly all its
covid restrictions
on june 15th although masks would still
be required
carter evans talked with the state's
embattled governor gavin newsom
who's facing a recall fight over his
handling of the crisis
looking back at your pandemic response
is there anything you would have done
different
i think everybody can look back because
we're all not experts we're geniuses
in hindsight the one word of the last
year's humility
all of us i think humbled with
california governor gavin newsom facing
a looming recall and harsh criticism
over a pandemic response that included
some of the most restrictive rules in
the country
his job could now depend on how quickly
his state recovers
this economy is reopening schools are
back in business and i think california
is uniquely positioned
to come roaring back california has been
slower than other states in the nation
to reopen schools
and reopen businesses what do you say to
parents
and business owners who feel like you
let them down well 9 000 of our 11 000
schools have either reopened for
in-person instruction
or have set a date to reopen for
in-person instruction
yeah but they've been out of school for
more than a year now at this point
other states have been back for months
yeah so we put out a
blueprint in december 6.6 billion
dollars to address
learning loss and we're looking to
extend the school year
extend the school day we also have the
third
highest unemployment rate in the nation
right now yeah and it's continuing to
drop
significantly and the reason our
unemployment is stubbornly high is
because the impact of the hospitality
and leisure industry
has been disproportionate what will
return and what is returning
is the opportunity for these businesses
to reopen still
more than two million californians have
signed a petition to force a recall
county officials have until april 29 to
determine if enough of those signatures
are valid
to trigger a special election it looks
like you're going to face a recall
election
in a few months i met some business
owners who are supporting the recall
effort against you
because they feel like the decisions you
made destroyed their livelihoods
know we put 2.5 billion dollars in small
business grants
california's the first state to do a
state home order
we have among the lowest death rates of
the major states in the country
we think we're better positioned than
most other states to come roaring back
and we're providing record amount of
relief
and support for small businesses has the
recall effort
influenced your decisions and pandemic
response absolutely not in fact
quite the contrary we're just focused on
the data disease prevalence i'm focused
on what's actually happening on the
ground
newsom also says that california met its
goal of administering 4 million doses to
people in the hardest hit zip codes
when you look at hispanics in california
they're roughly 40 percent of the
population
roughly half of the covet case is half
of the deaths yet they're about
22 percent of the vaccination and that's
why six about five weeks ago we
announced that 40 percent of all the new
first doses
are going under this new equity metric
look at the end of the day
it's still stubborn the equity metric
continues to be a challenge
good enough never is there is no having
made it now the governor says he expects
30 million doses to be administered by
the end of this month
and that puts california on track to
vaccinate
almost everyone who's eligible now the
governor also talked about the increase
in the number of migrants crossing the
border and how
california is preparing if you want to
head to cbs this morning on twitter
instagram or facebook to hear more
that's where you find it all right
meantime please continue watching us
carter thank you very much